hello there welcome to conan o'brien
needs a friend podcast for all people
everywhere if you enjoy humanity you'll
enjoy our podcast always trying out for
waiting
i'm so sorry what to enjoy humanity is
to enjoy conan o'brien needs a friend
yeah don't you mean like you listen to
this podcast and then you go oh the
humanity
like hindenburg yes yes that's
like the hindenburg great reference for
the kids kids love a good
hindenburg a good lakehurst new jersey
explosion joke um
no i i do think uh i i aim uh you know
for this to be a a podcast for the
people people everywhere we are not
this is not a niche
uh podcast there's no velvet rope up
here we are here to allow anyone who
wants joy and laughter
uh they're welcome you know that's nice
yeah as long as you listen to the
advertisers
and buy those
products to our very friendly little
club
uh no uh matt gourley good to see you hi
uh [ __ ] i mean hi yeah okay take it easy
last time you got on me about sounding
weird or creepy and high was still a
little yeah
and sona how are you you know what
i'm i'm okay okay just a simple fine is
good
i didn't
you know what you you were very just
like you know when i really think about
it you know it sounded like you actually
cared no no i know i'm an actor
you've taken a lot of training
it threw me off it sounded like you were
being sincere and i'm like wait is this
a real moment
it was not
uh no i uh i'm i'm excited that we're
here we're doing a podcast we're
together i get a good energy from you
guys and when i say that i mean
um
i maintain my own energy despite you oh
i think you mean like you're a vampire
sucking energy from us to exist right
yeah
uh no that would not be a lot of energy
that would be
not a lot of nutrition in there
um
i'm trying to think about what we uh
we're going to talk about today
wow i really haven't got nothing going
right now in my mind i don't know
well we could uh just we could we could
sit comfortably inside in silence i
think that will work
i don't i hate that so much ready one
two three
in fact before we start who will be the
first to break the size it would be me
well let's see it'll be like why now are
you uncomfortable with science
i'm not uncomfortable with silence i'm
just like i don't know i just when i
when i'm told to be silent that's when i
can't exactly you know what's
interesting i do know this about sona
over the years when i've asked her to
tone it down she gets crazy and she
really gets okay no no you do she gets
very like wide-eyed like what what don't
you tell me to lower my voice and
literally we'll be in a situation where
you know we could be in a room with
someone and they're operating like on a
child's eye
and i'm like sonia you got to keep it
down a little bit i don't have to keep
it down and the surgeon's like oops
blind for life little boy hold on every
time you're ready to tell the story you
make yourself sound so rational and so
calm and so collected but you're never
that way you were oh you're always like
i don't know you're just like
i don't know i'm a master impressionist
master impressionist
son of obsession all right everybody
guess this celebrity
um
yeah i um no you you do not like anyone
to suggest that maybe you could be a
little quieter and it's not and it's not
even part of a
i will speak and my voice will be heard
it's you know you will not mansplain to
me or be make me be silent it's not that
anyone could tell you in a very
appropriate situation where you need to
be a little more quiet like you know
we're trying to escape and
our guards are asleep right there so
let's get by and you'll start to
probably say something like you know
what it would be really good yeah if we
could go to one of those restaurants
where they have a tray and you get as
much as you want like a sizzler yeah and
i'd say and i'd say like you just don't
want to go to the center we're trying to
keep it down
a little bit because our captors are
right there and they're trying to wake
up don't you tell me i know i have to
say this narrative i mean you're pretty
loud too yeah you are yes yeah that's
true but you're you are he is right
though if you like right now you're
saying we should be quiet because you
said that i won't be let's try this okay
so now i'm going to write on this paper
000 bitcoin okay okay and
whoever stays quiet the lastest
okay
you know what you are right
these segments really are better when we
give them no thought beforehand what do
you mean i've been planning this for
ages all right okay so you want us to be
silent for as long as possible yeah on a
podcast
okay all right three two one
someone shot and i just won because you
spoke second no 300 000 bitcoin
no i was i know i thought it was whoever
spoke first
it was the longest i said the lastest to
speak last is to speak well
okay look how competitive you just got
by the way you got so angry i didn't
know i couldn't make like the noises
that's you wanted me to silence no
silence okay
we tried it it failed miserably okay and
i'm ready can we try it again sure
it's great podcasting
okay i'm upping it to three hundred and
ten thousand bitcoin
okay three two one
i can't do it
what's wrong with you seriously i win
610 000 bitcoin no okay that's fine matt
you can have i don't care about being
second
i just didn't want to be the first one
to talk well i mean this is i found that
that's weird that you can't do it
no no no no it's i can i can
no but what about like when you're twins
or asleep are you able to be quiet why
is that because nobody tells me to be
quiet i just your husband's happy tac
never says hey could you keep it down a
little bit no
no he knows he knows better he knows
better
he knows better but like nobody does if
i know him he's a victim of domestic
abuse
if you always have two black eyes every
time i see him if you if you say be
quiet i can't be
like if someone is
i remember once asking you to do
something for me and you said if you
asked me to do something i can't do it
and i said you're my assistant yeah
it was the most
it's a hilarious exchange you said i
have a problem sometimes when he this is
when we were talking to
someone who um
you know was trying to be like a couples
counselor with us yeah and and and how
we could work better in the office and
you said i just have a problem when he
asks me to
things
you're
do
i know but i'm being honest and i've
never pretended not to do that okay all
right here's a rap sign and also i just
want to put this up yeah well i don't
even know how do you get that i don't
know who's gonna give it to you i don't
know anything about cryptocurrency but i
know it's coming my way i go to a server
and there's a blockchain and a man in a
dark suit hands it to me i had it
not sensitive it's not important